madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir une
finale du championnat de france de rugby
qui opposera béziers à perpignan la
violence qui règne à nouveau en maître
en italie en espagne israël
à 48 heures de l'élection législative
est essentielle pour l'avenir de l'état
hébreu et enfin le retour de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber à la tête
du parti radical
voilà les grands titres de cette édition
de 20h titre que je vous propose de
développer maintenant avec l'ensemble de
la rédaction d'antenne
commençons par cette réélection ce
retour sur l'avant scène politique de
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
le député de nancy a retrouvé
aujourd'hui de président du parti
radical après un court intermède à
l'internet de deux ans le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que cette reconquête
n'aura pas été facile
rarement un comble et aura été aussi
agité et enfin du des plantes et de nord
il est vrai qu'un candidat solide
s'étaient dressés monsieur edgar faure
qui a tenté d'enlever de l'adhésion des
radicaux finalement le président de
l'assemblée nationale a échoué et après
sa défaite à pontarlier lors des
élections municipales c'est un coup dur
porté à l'ancien président du conseil
qui pour certains apparaît aujourd'hui
comme un éventuel recours ont obtenu
edgar faure 340 reiber 465 en
conséquence je proclamerai berre
président pour dedans du parti radical
socialiste
il aura fallu près de trois heures pour
arriver à décompter tous les bulletins
de vote dans les couloirs du congrès
certains délégués du parti et mettait
d'ailleurs des doutes quant à la
validité du scrutin
il est sûr que jamais dans un congrès
radical on aura parlé autant de combines
de magouilles et de tout table mais une
fois jean-jacques servan-schreiber élus
le parti est repris les deux candidats
se sont serrés la main chaleureusement
jjss atténuer ses attaques contre son
talent dur malheureux en revanche il
s'est placé dans la majorité en
concurrent direct de jacques chirac
il m'aurait paru funeste qu'il devienne
le maître seule de la majorité car ce
fut d'abord ça aurait été la voie la
plus directe vers la défaite et ensuite
ce n'était pas l'expression juste de ce
que ressentent les français alors qu'il
y ait maintenant un autre pôle
différents dans la majorité que le
dialogue public sur les problèmes des
français puis-je instauré entre les deux
c'est une excellente chose pour tout le
monde alors d'elle quoi est ce que cette
défaite de monsieur edgar faure est
aussi une défaite est peut-être plus
grave pour jacques chirac sans doute
cette défaite de messieurs gars forts
sur le plan politique comme étant la
conséquence d'une sorte de réflexe en
tenir p r nous avions signalé hier le
propos de madame françoise giroud
monsieur chirac que tente de mettre dans
sa poche le parti radical
or président interposés on a
l'impression que la majorité du parti
radical a voulu contre-attaqué porté un
coup à monsieur chirac par monsieur
edgar faure interposés la déclaration de
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
que nous venons d'entendre cet égard
significative
il semble bien que cette querelle
personnelle ce combat singulier auquel
nous avons assisté dans la fièvre
pendant 48 heures est en fait par delà
le parti radical ou à travers le parti
radical
une fable la lutte d influence qui se
développent actuellement à l'intérieur
de l'ensemble de la majorité et ce sont
je crois et toutes les formations de la
majorité qui se trouve actuellement dans
une période de réflexion
d'interrogations voire même de remise en
cause
ainsi par exemple cet après midi
monsieur lecanu et annoncé que son
mouvement le pdf allait tenir un congrès
extraordinaire au mois de septembre
prochain et c'est là que les centristes
vous soutenir leur stratégie dès
aujourd'hui ils annoncent qu'ils se
mobilisent ils sont unanimes derrière
monsieur raymond barre ou puis il
souligne que pour favoriser l'union de
la majorité
ils ont renoncé à l'idée d'une alliance
privilège formation les radicaux se sont
battus l'autre nom priest attendent mais
les uns les autres de profits nalement
en face du même problème qui est le
problème de l'organisation d'ensemble de
la majorité merci des copains pendant
que les radicaux de la planche donc
majorité se cherchait un président le
parti communiste rice et lui ce militant
à la villette événement attendu de cette
journée de cette seconde fête de paris
le discours de georges marchais en effet
après le refus de françois mitterrand
d'avaliser le bilan financier le
chiffrage financier du programme commun
publié il ya huit jours par le parti
communiste
on attendait la réaction du secrétaire
général du pc aujourd'hui devant ses
militants
georges marchais a mis les choses au
point l'union n'a de sens elle aboutit à
ce changement car l'union pour nous
n'est pas une fin elle n'est pas un
abstrait et d'un slogan électoral quoi
servirait-il changé de majorité de
changer de gouvernement
demain c'est la même politique qui
s'applique
les mêmes fils et les mêmes privations
on demande aux français jeunes bien le
dire ici très sereinement à la veille de
l'ouverture des négociations pour la
mise à jour du programme commun qu on ne
pompe pas du communisme de pour aller
dans cette voie note bab notre peuple
a connu dans le passé trop de mauvaises
surprises pour voir une nouvelle fois et
nous nous voulons vraiment une politique
nouvelle pour la france nous nous
voulons que des choses et qu'elle change
attendons maintenant la réunion de mardi
c'est en effet le 17 mai que les trois
partis composant l'union de la gauche
doivent se réunir pour la
réactualisation du programme commun
entre parenthèses je vous signale que
cet après midi leurs marchés a annoncé
qu'il aimerait bien lui aussi rencontré
le premier ministre dans une joute
télévisée
non sion nos mains et nos projets pour
la monsieur marc pour ma main j'y suis
prêt au bon dieu que vous choisirez le
8e temps que monsieur pas répondra par
l'affirmative à cette proposition
renouvelée car comment un homme d'une
telle envergure d'une défiance d'une tel
aviv
où est il donc avoir peur en attendant
cette éventuelle débat je vous rappelle
que mercredi prochain à 20h30 dans
l'émission cartes sur table la rédaction
d'antenne de jean pierre elkabbach vient
du hamel recevront justement monsieur
georges marque auprès parenthèse pour
évoquer les propos tenus il ya quelques
minutes seulement par monsieur michel
debré lors de l'émission le club de la
presse tu rentres numéro un j'ai relevé
deux phrases de l'ancien premier
ministre du général de gaulle
la première concerne monsieur raymond
barre le gouvernement a dit ce michel
debré à vocation pour diriger à la
veille des élections
le camp dont il a la responsabilité la
seconde phrase concerne les problèmes
parlementaire la peinture à dire michel
debré sans que cela entraîne
nécessairement une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale peut être voter
sur un problème d'intérêt national comme
celui de l'élection et des pouvoirs du
parlement européen
ouais donc pour la politique française
de ce dimanche à l'étranger deux pays
retiennent ce soir la tension ces deux
pays dont l'italie et l'espagne et pour
la même raison cette raison en italie
les manifestations se succèdent en effet
de plus en plus et elles prennent des
caractères de près grande violence les
armes à feu désormais en droit de cité
dans les rues des grandes villes
et cette radicalisation des
manifestations semblent entraîner
l'italie ce soir au bord de la guerre
civile
bram ce matin le bruit des sirènes les
charges de policiers le placement secte
des fusils d'assaut c'est le plus macho
tour de la grenade lacrymogène s'éclate
les gars qui prétendent aujourd'hui la
peur la compassion carrière la violence
dans tout dit elle
luc berthold qui provoque qui est de qui
vient à provocation la méfiance est le
seul lien fédérateur
les jeunes garçons filles lorsqu'ils
croisent et forces de l'ordre se demande
le coût de votre part pire les policiers
et les carabiniers
ceux qui sont là pour maintenir l'ordre
sont tout autant accueilli hier à milan
il est vrai une centaine de jeunes gens
le visage dissimulé par des foulards ont
délibérément tiré avec des armes de gros
camions les forces politiques
traditionnelles de droite de gauche du
centre n'ont pas en apparence la
possibilité de maîtriser une situation
qui semble n'appartenir à personne à la
provocation
l'espagne est l'autre connaît des heures
difficiles depuis trois jours des heurts
très violents opposent manifestants et
forces de l'ordre dans la province
depuis jeudi
cinq personnes ont été tuées dans le
pays basque par les portes de police qui
quadrillent tout le territoire
les manifestants réclament l'amnistié
générale pour les condamner encore
interférer dans les prisons espagnoles
aujourd'hui un calme précaire a régné au
pays basque
cependant tous les rassemblements de
population était interdite et c'est
ainsi que bilbao était ce matin et toute
la journée une ville morte
le tour d'espagne qui devait se terminer
avant sébastien a été dérouté vers la
province de burgos
dans moins de 48 heures les électeurs
israéliens vont choisir leur nouveau
député une élection difficile avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes après la
démission des général rabin deux hommes
sont actuellement réellement en présence
il s'agit de l'actuel ministre de la
défense monsieur shimon peres et du
leader de l'extrême droite monsieur
menahem begin avec peut-être un
troisième larron le général ya des
itzhak rabin le premier ministre déploie
deux jours plus tôt il a reconnu que sa
femme avait pris fait avec le fisc il
vient prendre pas à ton enterrement
politique après avoir accepté la
démission de rabin la réunion
extraordinaire du parti de travail
elie son successeur celui qui conduira
la liste du parti aux élections du 17
mai prochain
l'envy capital de ces élections rend
leur choix aisé
shimon peres ministre de la défense
l'homme le plus populaire du parti
perez n'aura pas une tâche certes depuis
la création d'israël il ya 28 ans les
travaillistes ont toujours été au
pouvoir
mais aujourd'hui ils ont peur le parkour
crew coup et depuis un an par une
cascade de scandales dont un ministre
accusé de corruption s'est suicidé un
haut conseiller du parti est en prime
rabin lui même a dû démissionner tout le
parc était clamousse eu une façon
réaliste nous pour avouer que cela a une
influence négative n'est ce pas sur
l'image que présente notre parti aux
électeurs d'autre part une propos
attribués à une collectivité les erreurs
les espaces individuels
ensuite je crois que nous avons
apportées mais de dire avec franchise
que nous avons tout fait pour éradiquer
ces phénomènes la candidature de cet
homme qui gagne à dean ancien général
professeur d'archéologie est la
conséquence de ces scandales
cette ambiance de corruption n'a pas
seulement terni l'image du gouvernement
ou du parti travailliste se sont tous
les partis tous les hommes politiques
d'israël qui ont été éclaboussés
il yad'une dit être en croisade
politique sauver israël des politiciens
son message est simple ça suffit il faut
des hommes neufs des hommes honnêtes
ses amis lui ont donné son surnom
monsieur prend
j'ai bien conscience de mes pires que
c'est ce problème de moralité politique
qui vous a poussé à être candidat oui
c'est la course mais ces histoires de
corruption récente le véritable sens de
ma campagne
c'est qu'il faut résoudre nos problèmes
économiques et nos problèmes sociaux qui
pour la plupart de la création mains
d'israël qui n'ont jamais été partout
travailliste et leurs scandales phase
iia dîner son inexpérience la droite
croient à ses chances dans une campagne
électorale en demi teinte
ils sont les plus d'une heure les thèmes
de cette campagne sont surtout d'ordre
intérieur car la paix dit on il dépend
en fait des arabes ou des amériques
alors israël se tourner vers les
problèmes socio économiques sur lesquels
les gens pensent que leurs votes auront
une réelle influence
et puis bien sûr il ya le problème de la
corruption
je crois que pour le moment dans ce coin
là on s'intéresse au problème de la
corruption des scandales qu'on a eu dans
le pays ces dernières années
le dernier mois tour et je crois que le
public pense que peut-être la réputée
perpétuation
du régime du parti du travail toutes ces
choses qui vont se dérouler ces
dernières années et ces choses peut se
changer demande s'il y aura un
changement de gouvernement c'est là tout
l'enjeu de ces élections quel sera le
parti qui dirigera israël en cette année
cruciale
les sondages montrent le danger que ni
les travaillistes ni la droite ni a dit
denis de majorité suffisante pour
s'attaquer vraiment aux problèmes dont
souffre en ce qu'a dit on ici
la seule solution serait un gouvernement
d'union nationale les électeurs
israéliens en tous les cas trancheront
cette semaine dans les grandes villes
vous le savez les enfants sont souvent
désarçonné ils ne savent pas finalement
comment s'intégrer à la vie de la cité
et ignorent tout de la vie à la campagne
certains volontaires essaie de combler
ce fossé qui sépare le monde de
l'enfance de celui des adultes
c'est le cas notamment d'une association
qui vient de se fonder et qui porte le
nom d'enfant dans la ville d'autres
tentent de rapprocher l'enfant de la
nature
c'est ainsi que le jardin
d'acclimatation à paris va ouvrir cette
semaine un mini zoo c'est ainsi aussi
qu'à lille une perm pour enfants
accueille les adolescents dans ses
expériences
une chose est permanente les enfants
doivent faire la connaissance des
animaux comme les tigres et les
éléphants sont remplacés par des chèvres
ou bien par des cochons demande à la
maîtresse est l'enfant du béton de
crayonnés un magnifique volatiles monté
sur quatre pattes
une histoire qui ne risque plus
d'arriver à ces enfants de l'île qui
viennent chaque mercredi à la ferme pour
en compte anglo installée au fond du
parking d'un hypermarché de la grande
banlieue lilloise
cette ferme déclaré pilote il ya deux
ans par le ministère de la qualité de la
vie a fait maintenant ses preuves au
poids que l'on pense sérieusement à
doter les grandes villes de l'hexagone
comme cela se fait déjà couramment en
anglais comme en allemagne à englos tout
a commencé grâce aux bêtes le che
éleveurs amateurs nombreux dans le nord
qui tentent de reconstituer les rats
disparu pour aller de l'animal oublier à
l'enfant du veto ils créèrent d'une
ferme
nous sommes partis du principe que il
fallait que les enfants viennent aux
animaux n'ont pas la verte et
nous avons voulu aussi il découvre
beaucoup chaud c'est à dire qu'on avec
l'animal on peut faire un peu de
géographie d'histoire en fait tout et
surtout de la protection de la nature de
manière vivant c'est c'est l'enfant qui
est admis chez des amis mais c'est tout
à fait d'accord et donc il faut que les
jeunes s'habituent au contact avec ces
bêtes que des bugs sont en parfaite
sécurité
la plupart d'entre eux doivent être
assez convaincus vous pu avoir d'animaux
chez soi et ils préfèrent venir
s'occuper ici où ils en ont vraiment un
minimum
il y en avait tiré paix d'avoir des
chèvres c'est mieux quand elles ont vu
ce qu'ont été ces horribles êtres chers
dans une ferme
ils ont bien compris que ma maison se
défend femmes dans le même temps au
jardin et l'animal domestique nous avons
ce n'est pas une fin en soi ça nous
permet de découvrir tout un autre monde
au début on aime bien les caresser de
sable maintenant pour beaucoup mieux
c'est ce qu'on s'en occupe
parce que il s'occupa de les caresser en
lait on nettoie ont fait leur big air et
ou alors c'est plus intéressant du vin
ça commence comme de très soutenu parce
que jean bricmont a parlé comme ça moi
il y avait pour moi une patte allemande
a souhaité agir en faire un petit peu
comme un jardin dans une fille un jardin
dans un champ englos il a fallu refuser
une centaine d'enfants mais dans six
mois il y aura une deuxième faire mal il
juste à côté du centre administratif sur
le terrain des andaines subventionné par
la municipalité secrétariat à la
jeunesse et des sports
cette ferme a été conçu à partir des
conseils des animateurs dans blues ont
pu reposer une telle expérience sur du
bénévolat
il faut que grâce à une épine équipes
fixes nous puissions avoir à la fois des
éleveurs et des pédagogues ce n'est pas
facile à trouver des gens capables de
très dynamique dans une ville autour des
animaux vautours de la ferme à
destination des associations des écoles
de tout ce qui forme la vie de la ville
parce que l'animal est présent partout
et on peut réussir à utiliser l'animal
partout avec les enfants une idée qui
devra faire son chemin
essentiellement du côté des enseignants
des éducateurs ce qui n'est pas encore
le cas
pas de surprise pour la finale du
championnat de france de rugby béziers
vainqueur hier de nice rencontrera dans
quelques semaines le 29 mai très
exactement et à paris perpignan qui a
illuminé
aujourd'hui roman une finale
intéressante la sixième en tout cas en
sept ans pour les biterrois
nous voici en deuxième mi-temps
perpignan un maillot bleu ciel mène 3 à
puis la 27ème minute grâce à une
pénalité de l'open voici l'essai de
perpignan marquer en force thaïs kirby
le pilier de l'usap année c'est que nous
allons revoir au ralenti et qui
concrétise la domination territoriale
des catalans cet après midi
lopez roger nist qui va donner la balle
à isquierdo et celui ci en force va
marquer un essai comme à la parade
voilà les seins puis 110 cars 2 c garcia
qui réussit la transformation 9 à 0 pour
perpignan le break est fait à ce
moment-là l'usap sort le grand jeu
attaquer tout va comme aux plus beaux
jours coup de pied à suivre de lopez
on attend la réaction de roman mais ce
sont les catalans qui ceux qui
poursuivent ce ballon la furia catalane
comme on a l'habitude de dire romans
essais de réagir tant bien que mal
tentative de serre vient tout seul qui
dribble deux adversaires parvient à
passer
mais une fois de plus lerman et vont se
heurter à la défense catalane très bien
regroupée cet après midi et regardez
bien cette action encore une attaque de
romans qui essaient de refaire son
retard attention vous
et voilà comment ton est plaqué à du
petit père millions on et leicester bien
passé il faut cette victoire à tout prix
les catalans veulent jouer la finale
contre berne
petit coup de pied à suivre de l'open
voit là l'occasion de romans l'occasion
de réduire la marque sur cette action la
balle est mal contrôlée par le ps qui se
tait contraire et servir le demi
d'ouverture de romans pour retrouver la
balle parvient à aplatir en coin un
essai que vous voyez maintenant pour
allan poe servient qui n'a pas été très
heureux dans ses tentatives de coup de
pied au but cet après midi va tout de
même parvenir à transformer cet essai en
coin 9 à 6 ouvre les catalans de
leicester perpignan
voyez la dernière action dieu ne
permettra pas vraiment de refaire son
handicap et finalement perpignan va se
qualifier aux dépens de romans 9 à 6 cet
après midi pour la première fois depuis
22 ans du sabre au clair les judokas
français pourront revenir satisfait des
championnats d'europe leur moisson de
médailles fait honneur ou quatre cent
mille licenciés de la fédération
aujourd'hui l'équipe de france est en
finale de la compétition par équipes
cela signifie qu'au pire elle ramènera
une médaille d'argent médaille
s'ajoutant à celles remportées hier chez
les légers et en toutes catégories et le
résultat nous est parvenue la france se
contentera ce soir paris coupe de la
médaille d'argent à ces championnats
d'europe la france était ordinaire tout
même remporté six médailles au total
dans les neuf compétitions disputées et
on aurait préféré effectivement une
médaille d'or pour la finale par équipe
l'urss a battu la france 4 victoires à 3
ici dans cette compétition par équipes
volantes soft déjà champions d'europe
des moyens ont davantage sur hairabedian
l'otan fait à droite passe maintenant à
gauche
mais rouge et a une nouvelle fois battu
son rival de la finale des lourds ni
arad
la france avait pris le titre à kiev
langon biopolitique les soviétiques leur
frenzen le judo français se porte bien
400 me licencier la fédération française
est un exemple pour tous toujours elle
ces soutiers du devenir des athlètes
favorisant de façon exemplaire la
promotion du sportif les résultats
aujourd'hui sont là et la volt offre à
gagné par ippon france médaille d'argent
la france c'est un autre sport entre en
lice ce soir au festival du cinéma à
cannes avec un film qui est très attendu
il s'appelle la communion solennelle un
film qui était bien accueilli lors de sa
sortie dans les salles obscures par la
critique un film signé en tout cas par
un jeune réalisateur rené féret un film
enfin réuni 130 acteurs dont ce
réalisateur france roche est à cannes
pour nous pour entonner ses invités
célèbres et ceux qui voudraient bien
l'être
les robes souvent applaudi les smokings
quelquefois loup et bien sûr l'ombre et
la lumière
dans la lumière inauguration du festival
est loin du festival loin des pales à un
jeune couple modeste dans un hôtel
mauvaise
michel là et rené féret productrice et
réalisateur du premier film français
présenté en compétition
la communion solennelle ils ont quitté
pour 15 jours saint maur et leur
pavillon de banlieue en pierre meulière
et leur fils jules le 4e julien de leur
vie et bonheur film car la communion
solennelle qui comporte trois héros
baptisé julien de père en fils et
l'histoire de leur propre famille depuis
1890 je crois que l'héritage là qu'ils
veulent vous avez donc réellement des
parents qui étaient paysans et des
parents qui étaient milliard oui
absolument
ma mère l'a vu elle a été très très très
heureuse de le voir je crois la vue
trois femmes blanches et la l'a reconnu
il a reconnu effectivement les histoires
qu'elle raconte est cependant les
familles se dispute en à des drames on a
comme on dit des cadavres dans les
placards
oui mais c'était peut-être que je crois
pas que je n'ai que je ressorte
finalement il aménage un petit bureau
désert toujours en banlieue pour
produire d'autres films leur passé s'est
plutôt déroulée dans les coulisses des
théâtres ou féret débuté à 14 en amateur
puis en professionnel jouer dans des
maisons de la culture aux quatre coins
de la france avant de monter à paris et
en même temps je jouais dans la
compagnie à son jeune âge est animateur
dans une maison des jeunes à clichy se
souvient on s'est quitté au mois de juin
il faut que chacun écrit un scénario
pour la rentrée et puis quand on s'est
tous retrouvés à la rentrée en septembre
moi j'avais écrit un scénario est ici un
petit peu et puis alors là d'un seul
coup j'ai j'ai dit c'est suisse et mon
fils qu'il faut faire c'est
effectivement celui là qu'on a fait
c'est déjà votre femme qui s'en était
occupée oui oui on s'est rencontré
d'ailleurs culte
juste au moment où on a fait l'histoire
de paul est à la fois une rencontre
professionnelle aboyer de
l'administration théâtrale c'est cela
moses dans le 4 mai de l'autre côté je
suis encore de la copine commanditant
quand on produit des films sans argent
qui ne rapporte pas d'argent on vit mal
pour l'instant vit mal on vit on
travaille pour la sans travail on n'est
pas payé et on est on est au chômage
parce que on subit le la forme de
travail de travailleurs intermittents du
spectacle donc on a des salaires pendant
trois mois
pas très importants et le résultat en
violation de chômage on attend on espère
que comme vous que sur la communion
c'est la dernière fois vous n'aurez plus
à quoi réunion le fallait quant à mr et
laïta sort bien la sones tu pourrais
faire un effort aux masters je peux lui
parler quand je veux et toi tu commence
à m'emmerder
j'ai atteint les arêtes arrêté je vous
en supplie moyen de dieu j'ai le démolir
communion solennelle de repérer ce soir
au festival de calme le prix rieussec
mais les parieurs à sec ce vieil adage
des champs de course a été confirmée
aujourd'hui le 23 le 3 et le 8 en
arrivant dans cet ordre nous permettent
en effet d'augurer un tiercé assez élevé
peut-être aux alentours de 10 mille
francs
les vainqueurs seront donc relativement
assez peu nombreux daniel handicap de
3300 m de bout en bout n'est pas une
chose facile et c'est pourtant l'exploit
car son état qui a réalisé à stioui le
numéro 23 cet après midi à longchamp en
tête depuis le départ
à ce titre il aborde le dernier tournant
devant st pognon tetra qu'hbo charles et
levant tôt dès le début de la ligne
droite à steel wheels bien calé le long
de la corde est attaqué par saint fognon
des tracts 3 au charles wuyts suivent
tout près c'est donc entre ses chevaux
le tiercé va se disputer car aucun autre
concurrent ne parviendra à se mêler à la
lutte
encore 400 mètres de course à ce titre
il ne s'avoue pas vaincu tetrax se
rapproche très vite toujours entre payet
de boshab le sprint est lancé
les cravaches soleil car c'est à cet
endroit que les chevaux doivent donner
le meilleur d'eux mêmes à steel wheels
très courageusement parviendra jusqu'au
bout a repoussé la bonne attaque finale
de petra
quant à bouchard malgré tous ces efforts
de changer à la lotto il devra se
contenter de la troisième place
les autres étaient vite battu sans
exclure retire ses 23
pour moi la vie bien voilà les rapports
vous les voyez juste devant vous 11300
46 francs pour 5 francs dans l'ordre le
23 le 3 et le 8 et dans un ordre
différent 2194 offrant 50 toujours pour
5 francs il n'a pas fait très beau
aujourd'hui sur la france et la météo
n'est pas particulièrement optimiste
pour demain les spécialistes nous
promettent en effet des vosges à la
provence et la corse un temps très
nuageux et passagèrement pluvieux tandis
que des éclaircies se développeront dans
le nord et le nord-est sur le reste de
la france
le temps sera très frais pour la saison
le ciel sera variable avec des averses
localement fortes et pouvant être
orageuses avec aussi des vents de nord
ouest assez fort cette édition est
maintenant terminée à 23h30 pour notre
dernière édition vous retrouverez hélène
vida bonne soirée à tous
à